c'est un truc de malade mec ou à cette
maison et qui regarde la déco pas
désagréable pour ce soir et ouais
franchement ça va être une dinguerie sur
les marches bon délire tu les as vous
pouvez voyager des prix on voit de quoi
je sors tout tient alors ça je me dis
pas que tu les oublies la solution à
temps j'appelle micky est peut-être
qu'il aura quelque chose pour wayne mc
je suis de déranger en un problème on a
perdu les acred temps n'aura pas de
peindre
j'ai eu un désistement mais j'ai pu voir
qu'une place lorsque je faire si je vais
vous l'envoyez tout de suite je vous
envoie une bagnole vous l'apprenez mais
démerdez vous avec ça
sopel est ce mal au festival de cannes
en plus que j'allais l'année dernière
j'ai un rendez vous avec un réal mais
qui n'a jamais rien offert à noël pour
une fois fait un effort et alors c'est
mon anniversaire dans quelques jours
t'inquiète pas on va trouver une
solution
laissez moi juste aller aux toilettes
avant et attend sa compagne d'accord
ça que tu veux
oui
merci c'est gagné
tu te rends compte mais je vais enfin
pouvoir monter les marches
quand on a créé comme on accède ou non à
l'eau mike